hi i'm kat dennings and i play jewels
hey i'm brenda song and i play madison
hi i'm shea mitchell and i play stella
hi i'm esther pavitsky and i play izzy
and we are the cast of doll face and
we're here to take the bff test
i know all of your birthdays i don't
know any of your birthdays
brenda i know i've wished you happy
birthday on your birthday but i don't
know when that was i love you very much
cat you're june 13th yes esther your
march 2nd my god uh you're april 10th
oh my you just you have a very good
memory guys i'm a really good memory i
feel like such a
dif honestly none of us should be
surprised of course
okay well none of you guys should be
surprised i know zero of these about
anybody so
their middle name i only know two i know
my middle name i only know two of you
guys names hey your name is shannon that
is true right yeah but that's my name
shannon ashley mitchell
and then i know cats i don't know esther
i don't know yours but cat is catherine
victoria yes but i don't need your
zester i'm esther lauren esther lauren
what's yours brenda i don't have one
that's right okay so that's a true
question
their favorite snack oh god well we all
love many snacks yeah but the favorite
snack it's like on set snack or like
meal or wait esther you like those
healthy fake bars i love those thank you
for reminding me yeah
okay shea
popeyes
or ramen or like ramen i feel like she
carries like it in her bag
cat and brenda are uni yeah we love yeah
that's true but like it's like a snack
that had to like bring with us i feel
like you got me to those bobo bars oh
yeah the boba bars spin drift gummy
bears you were gummy bears last night oh
yeah gummy bears cat is a gummy bear
queen i think we could all check this oh
got this one oh celebrity crush we don't
need to say mine out loud okay
i i i do actually i think i at least
know two of your guys is let's keep all
of those a secret
let's agree to move on okay but i know
cats hers is andrew w.k
the first time you met at the reading
for the show
esther and i actually met at the
audition the producer she went right
before me yeah brenda and i auditioned
back to back we sat in the waiting room
together and i remember being like oh my
god is that brenda's song she's so cool
and brendo had not slept she was like
for like a long time all night
she was just like
i haven't slept she was a mess i was a
mess i'm surprised the shade that you
and i hadn't met before i know well you
guys we all met when you guys were all
auditioning me it was three against one
like being an amphitheater with just
shay reading yeah oh my god not awkward
about the part
from ending from tokyo it was all good
their favorite project of yours i'm a
huge fan of everybody here but i can't
really name that many yeah thing well i
don't watch anything i don't know what
i've been in
dolphins
their favorite swear word we're a big
fan of all of them right yeah
i mean we don't really discriminate when
it comes to swear words no we're really
bad at this game guys we'll say that we
all got that one too okay their go-to
karaoke song i mean i know mine
i don't i've never karaoke what's your
shay i'm like that i can't figure out
yeah like what is yeah what would yours
be honestly i'd have to say like rolling
in the deep adele like i like to go
do it wow
yeah mine is superman by eminem mine is
like a virgin by madonna it's more about
the dance mm-hmm
again i've never done it
wait i did have like a ps2 karaoke game
and i would really smash down son of a
preacher man alone there you
i
go
i'm pretty sure like i though those last
few were a little all over the place i i
feel like i didn't um i'm learning
this song and brenda is the bff for all
of us
i swear we know a lot about each other
but two different things the snack
question we all
nailed that one what a great race
buzzfeed thank you buzzfeed be sure to
watch all new episodes of doll face only
on hulu
so madison have me to know your birth
dates and middle names also very creepy
of me we're so lucky we have a brenda
we'd be so screwed